Earle Hall, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Good, and how about you?
I am doing just fine.
Where are you talking from right now?
I am in the beautiful city
of Las Vegas, Nevada USA.
Las Vegas, Nevada.
And what are you doing
in Las Vegas, Nevada?
I'm building
an artificial intelligence company.
We've been at it
for almost 10 years right now.
We pick up data out of slot machines
from about 50 countries right now.
And our goal with that data
is to bring forward algorithms
for anti-money laundering
to cure responsible gaming.
And with covid,
we're doing a lot of things
in the cashless world.
So, we've been at this for a long while.
We're not really a startup.
So Earl, this is a fascinating industry,
and it's particularly fascinating to me
because I know nothing about it.
So, aside from the fact that I enjoy
the occasional trip with friends,
and I myself am more of a poker guy,
but first I have to go back a little bit.
And you have a long history
with technology,
not just AXES.ai
but all the way
I'd love to go back to your growing up.
And you just mentioned
you had a pretty fascinating take
on your interaction with computers.
Talk to me a little bit about that.
Well, I grew up in a very small place.
It's a little tiny island right out
in the North Atlantic in Canada
called Newfoundland,
or Newfoundland as we call it at home.
Like Come From Away, from the musical.
Yes, but exactly that.
Not far from where I was born, actually.
And the issue was,
one, I was very blessed that even though
we were in a small place,
relatively modest place,
we did have computers in school
back in the early 1980s.
Wow.
But what freaked me out is that
outside of the mathematics
of making a sign curve,
the actual result
of a computer back then
was pretty stupid.
There was no difference between
the real world and the virtual world.
And that's really what I didn't like
as I graduated through computers,
went into the army.
And then, just to talk about the army,
then I saw the intelligence
that we were using back then
to keep a tank's muzzle
pointed towards the target.
And that's where my heart
started to beat this,
and if you can keep the muzzle straight
while the vehicle is moving,
then I started looking at how artillery
was projecting, getting into precision,
and then my heart started to beat
for artificial intelligence.
Wow.
Then I said okay-
Wait.
Yeah, go ahead sorry.
Already back then, you were thinking about
artificial intelligence?
We've come up with all these buzzwords now
that are okay, but the thing is,
for me, it's predictability.
If you look at the human psyche,
we have two things that keep us out
of the present moment:
we have fear of reproducing the past
or regret from the past,
or we have things from the past
giving us fear
that are predicting negative things
of the future.
And that's really the way
the animal brain works.
That's the way
we get all polluted with cortisol
and things inside of our brain.
So for me back then
I didn't have the word
artificial intelligence
until really the movie Matrix
that I worked on with my team
in special effects for movies.
But for me, the word was predictability.
How are they predicting
keeping that straight
with everything that's going on?
And that's when mathematics
really started to make my heart beat.
So, mathematics make your heartbeat.
Give me a couple sentences
about MIT, Matrix,
what's that all about?
Well, I was working in a company,
I was building a company that was doing
some very advanced scanning
of human bodies
to be able to move them
into the virtual world,
and then morph them onto wire frames
so we could do animation.
And when I actually understood
what the movie The Matrix
was trying to project as an
artificial intelligence world saying,
"Warning, Red Flag."
I went, "Oh my God. Okay, good.
Now, I get it."
And at the same time,
I was recruited to teach
at the master's degree level
in management of information.
So, I'll be honest,
now that it's a long time ago,
I used to use my students as guinea pigs
to do all kinds of papers
on things that were edge back then.
Wow.
To try to get food into my brain,
to understand where the world was going.
Predictability.
So, how do you end up
in the gaming industry?
You're now talking to me from Las Vegas.
And I'd love to, in a second, dive into
what is the gaming industry,
what is anti-money laundering,
and what is the role of AI
within the gaming industry.
But before that,
how do you make that transition?
I was in a totally different world.
I was actually in a totally
different part of the world.
And I got approached by
one of the large accounting firms
that a company in the gaming space
was going bankrupt
because of the fact that
they had a lot of patents,
a lot of potential,
but they ran out of cash
and they needed to be restructured.
So, I was parachuted in
to restructure that.
And I'll be honest,
I had never been in a casino
in my entire life.
Wow. Up to that point, of course.
Picked up the company, fixed it,
it ended up getting sold.
And towards the end before it got sold,
I got asked
by a very prestigious shareholder
that's one of my mentors,
"Please come help me build this company
that I have here."
And when I saw what he was doing
I was completely in trouble
because it was the intersection
of all of my dreams.
Big data,
wouldn't be able to do it
without blockchain,
and it was 100% taking me
in the direction where I wanted to go
of building an app store
to be able to welcome any app
in the planet onto the big data.
And all of that was fueling my vision
to get towards AI.
So, my mentor actually
rolled out a red carpet for me
to live my tech dream.
Wow. That's just incredible.
Okay. So, you're now finding yourself
in Las Vegas in the gaming space.
Give me a little bit of context,
because I know very little
about the gaming space,
let alone Las Vegas.
And I'm sure that
a lot of my friends also,
while we may enjoy it
from time to time,
we don't really understand
this ecosystem of what's happening there.
So, give me a little bit of background.
Well, we're kind of a stranger
to the entire industry,
because the industry was brought up
on slot machines and table games.
And data was largely localized
inside of all of the casinos.
Back in the old days
it was because of trust issues,
and today, it's largely
because of technology issues.
So, we showed up out of the blue
with a vision that was very much
years ahead of everybody else by saying,
We've got to get all of the data out
and get it into the cloud
so that we can manage performance,
we can manage KYC,
we can manage regulatory issues.
But at the same time,
our job is to bring in things
that can cure and advance the industry.
So, what does that mean
cure and advance?
So, cured of what?
And what does it mean
to advance the gaming industry?
Well, there are a lot of places
around the world
that still have legitimacy issues
with gaming where there's two things:
either it's a safe haven for crime,
or it's a potential area
where addiction can infiltrate in.
So, most people don't see that gaming
can bring in those things,
but I can tell you,
I travelled almost 100 countries
for this project I'm building,
and you see a lot of crazy stuff
around the world.
A lot.
A hundred countries?
Yeah. And you see a lot of crazy stuff.
Yup. Well over 100,
but I round it down to 100.
So, the thing is is that
what's driving our passion is that
we can actually bring in
a little bit of light
into some dark spaces.
Like when you hook in our system
into a jurisdiction,
into a place, into a casino,
the money laundering
... a lot of trouble
because we trace every single click,
every single movement,
every single change.
And our algorithms
are monitoring anything
that's outside of the normal.
So, if somebody is in there
trying to launder money,
we pick  them up in a heartbeat.
Wow. So, what have you seen
happen around the world
as you're putting in these technologies?
Give me a little bit
of the insight over there.
Well one of the things, I guess,
is like any consumer based industry,
like if you read any of the stuff
that Wal-Mart's been putting out
over the years
that the greatest threat to theft
in a Wal-Mart
is usually employees.
Well, it goes without saying
that one of the greatest threats
inside of the casino industry
is collusion between an employee
and an outside force.
Like I've seen in Guatemala,
unfortunately,
that organized crime actually
were threatening
with bodily harm employees
inside of a casino
that if they weren't helping them
rig the cards on a back or a game,
that members of their family
would be hurt or even worse.
Wow.
So, this is a little bit different also
from the classic movie 21
that we're all familiar with
where it's genius mathematicians
counting cards.
It sounds like the whole
the money laundering industry
within the gaming industry
is a little bit
more complicated than that.
It's a lot more complicated,
and it's very invisible
because of the fact that
it's getting very sophisticated
Sure.
which means that if you have a server,
you have an information management system
that's in one casino
and there's a different one
in another one,
well, the money launderers
and the card counters
on the blackjack side,
they will just dabble in different places
so that they're so far under the radar
of what any algorithm inside
of a one lone silo place could offer
in terms of intelligence, richness,
big data, micro data sets,
you'll never find them.
But when you're running
big data algorithms
like the algorithms we have,
we start by running them
over the whole planet.
So, they're running over 50 countries.
Wow.
Then we bring them down into regional,
then we bring them down
into micro algorithms.
So, as I'm sure you know,
there's a big difference
between big data and micro data.
We do both,
because you have to catch them
wherever they're trying to cheat the data.
And so, walk me through the process
of catching somebody
who's trying to cheat the data.
Oh, that's not our job.
I stay away from that.
No no no, not the physical.
because they'll come after me
and bury me.
All we do is,
we get a flagged transaction that says,
"This transaction looks suspecting"
and the email goes off
to the appropriate person, and that person-
What could be a trigger of that, though?
So, could that be that they're winning
an unexpected amount of money?
Oh, they don't want to win.
They don't want to win.
What they want to do
is cash in money, play a little bit
so that the unclean money
goes into a legitimate machine.
Right.
You play a little bit,
and then you take it back out
so that it becomes
a legitimate amount of money
because it's been cashed in
to that environment.
Then you might see in sophisticated places
where they'll move
to one machine to another
to bring down the actual amount
that they're going to cash out.
There's several different models
I'd like to call it,
but it's all the same thing;
it's trying to move money
out of a legitimate source
into a legitimate system.
Wow.
So, now that AXES.ai
have been around for about 10 years
and you're operating in 50 countries,
how big is the problem today?
How big is cheating in casinos today?
I'm not going to say it's alarming
because of the fact that
a lot of the countries
that were behind in technology
are now leaping forward in technology.
Like if you look at Mexico,
which was really a place
that needed to be cleaned up very bad
about 15 years ago,
when you look at it today,
it's using cashless technology,
it's using all kinds of algorithms,
it's really taking leaps forward.
The problem is not, what I'd like to say
a 911 in the language we use here
in the United States,
but it's a serious problem
that has to be dealt with
on a global level.
That's the reason why I'm a big fan
of a cashless society,
because if you can't move dirty money
into a clean space, well,
you can only be inside
of a clean environment.
And I know that
you're also pretty involved
with blockchain in general,
so I assume that
the passion for that
comes from a similar understanding, right?
Well, it's because AI is dependent
on the integrity of the data it's using.
If you can manipulate the data,
if you can skew the data,
if you can delete the data,
your algorithm is actually corrupt
without you knowing it.
Whereas if you're using
any form of blockchain,
whether it be centralized
or decentralized blockchain
I really don't care,
you're saying that the security
and the integrity of the data
is the underlying food
that you're feeding the algorithms.
Definitely.
That's why AI without blockchain,
for me, is whatever.
When you started out AXES.ai
and you're trying to build these models
that are looking at the gaming industry,
and I can only imagine
'cause you go into a casino,
there's so many
different types of machines,
so many different types of behaviors
that could happen,
and it's really a fascinating realm
from a psychological aspect.
But do you have to onboard people
that are specialized in gaming
or there's simply great engineers
and you're explaining to them
how the gaming industry works?
Because you yourself,
it doesn't sound like
you're a gamer by heart, right?
No, I'm not.
And I'll say that I've been blessed
at AXES,
because when I look at my whole team
around the world
and the different offices we have,
I'm surrounded by geniuses.
Whether they like gaming or not
has no bearing on what we do,
because, the second blessing of any leader,
and I'm going to say this
for the startups
not for the large mega companies
on the DOW or whatever,
but if you're smart enough as a leader,
you'll let your clients teach you.
My first sentence
that I always give to my clients is,
"Hey, I don't know your business.
And I'll be honest,
I'll probably never know it
as good as you do.
So, if you teach me
what you need to teach me
so that I can protect you
and give you tools
to go bigger, better, faster, I say
we'll have a great marriage together"
So, we do have people on our team
that know gaming,
but that's not the heart of who we are;
who we are is listening to our clients
and following them on their path.
What does a casino look like
in 5, 10 years
given that we go back
to in-person entertainment
and all of that?
You've just hit it on the nose.
Online gaming is becoming the staple
for somebody who wants to spin
a virtual slot machine for 10 minutes,
and win, lose or whatever, it doesn't matter.
But at the end of the day,
a casino is really
a gathering point for entertainment.
Even in the smallest little casinos
that I've been in
in Africa or in the Philippines
or anywhere else,
there's always an intersection
between food, between social,
between playing that
20, 40, 60, 80 dollars
that you have in your pocket.
And I'll always believe
that bricks and mortar
are going to be around forever,
because, as covid has shown us,
everybody who ran home in March goes,
"Yes, work from home."
Then the personality types
started to emerge between May, June, July,
and we realized some people need to be
in a social environment all the time,
some people don't want to be
in a social environment any time.
But the majority,
the 60% that are living
on the top of the bell curve,
they need to be in a social environment
some of the time, all the time.
Earle, this was all fascinating.
Before we leave, last question,
'cause we talked about this
briefly before, talk to me a little bit
about neuroscience, AI,
something that you're particularly excited
or scared about.
Give me your one or two minute brief
about your understanding
of neuroscience and AI,
and where you're in it?
Well, I'm dug in deep to the relation
between the pituitary gland
and the pineal gland.
Why? Because the pituitary gland
is really the seat of the animal brain,
and the pineal gland is really the seed
of the human brain.
And they're constantly in conflict
between fight and flight
and trying to find that Zen moment
where you're inspired
to really be who you are.
Right.
And the more that I looked at technology
over the last 20 years,
I realized that the only way
to understand artificial intelligence
or enhanced intelligence,
is to understand the difference between
the lower and the higher brain.
So, I started to dig in,
and I dug in for personal reasons.
I lived a very traumatic event
in my personal life with my son.
And I set out on a journey
to fix what I broke with my son.
And that just led me in a direction
that was so beautiful,
because today, when I look forward,
I see the human,
I see information technology,
I see the intersection,
and I'm putting back on my warrior suit
to make sure that
I'm on the right side of this fight.
I just love it.
Earle, this was so insightful
and so inspiring.
Thank you for taking the time to do this.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Inspiring others to be themselves.
I think it's the hardest thing
a human has to figure out,
it's to learn how to be
and trust themselves.
So, that's really a big part of my job is
sticking the mirror in my team's faces
and making them realize
how absolutely beautiful they really are.
Earle, thank you very, very much.
This was just wonderful.
Continue doing good for the world.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you very much for the invite.
I absolutely love what you're doing.
Congratulations.
Thank you. Bye bye.
Take care.